radical and repugnant reactionary
Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green globally debased and humiliated
herself yesterday during a hearing this
is a hearing during which she attacked
the witness
um Alejandro mayorkas and also accused
fellow member of the House Eric swalwell
of
um I guess sleeping with a Chinese spy
was the language that she used we're
going to look at that in a moment this
was so against not only common sense and
decorum but also the rules of these
hearings that Marjorie Taylor green was
banned from speaking for the rest of the
hearing after this completely unhinged
rant here she calls majorcus a liar
her words are taken down and then it is
noted that she is no longer allowed to
speak no longer allowed to speak
outrage
complete rage
poisoning our teenagers poisoning our
young people how long are you going to
let this go on
congresswoman let me assure you that
we're not letting It Go on we are
fighting the screen no I reclaim my time
you're a liar you are letting this go on
and the numbers well no
no actually I want you to take the words
of the speaker down
so in uh making a ruling on this uh it's
pretty clear that the rules State you
can't impugn someone's uh character uh
identifying or calling someone a liar is
unacceptable in this committee and I
make the ruling that we strike those
words
sorry just a point about a legitimate
question you're recognized our thank you
Mr chairman did you move to take the
words down or to strike them Mr Thompson
yeah sorry I just stepped in
to take them down
so that's what we do yeah yeah my
understanding is if words are taken down
that means that the the member can no
longer speak in whatever the proceeding
is
oh boy those words were said
I
that's Congressman Goldman there
personal inquiry point of personal
inquiry that's there's no such thing
that's the best point of personal
inquiry please that doesn't exist
Marjorie sorry second house uh when we
strike it does terminate the time of the
individual who is speaking yes so uh the
gentlelady is no longer recognized
the chair now recognizes Mr Ivy I
believe uh can I make a point of inquiry
Mr chairman you can so the the ruling
was that because she used the word liar
um that was taken down which I agree
with yes but but accusing a statement of
fact is very similar to the posters that
uh Mr there's no statement of fact
there's no statement there's no there's
no actual basis for the statement we're
not here to debate this okay and the
ruling was made by the chair that these
previous words were not against the
rules of
Clause one and Clause 4 of rule 17 but
to tell someone that they are a liar is
all right so Marjorie Taylor green
losing her right to speak these people
are really the worst of the worst of
American politics at this point and I
have to say that for me one of the it's
sad enough
that there are districts in this country
with a majority of those who choose to
vote willing to vote for nonsense like
Marjorie Taylor green that's sad in and
of itself that someone like her can even
become an elected member of the House of
Representatives but the even sadder part
is that there are many people in this
country magatypes who will see this and
they'll say she was right
he is a liar and she is being silenced
because the left perceives her to be
such a strong force again
completely delusional
imaginary made-up scenario bonus clip
she also goes after friend of the show
Congressman Eric swalwell a Democrat on
the committee and it's hard to imagine a
less less classy moment than this
said that he was going to declare dead
Con 3 on the Jews Mr secretary do you
believe that all of us have a
responsibility to elevate our rhetoric
and to denounce anti-Semitism and
anti-police rhetoric in this country so
that Jewish Americans and police
officers can be safer
Congressman I do thank you and I yield
back
the gentleman yields and now I recognize
the gentlelady from Georgia Miss Green
that was quite entertaining from someone
that had a sexual relationship with a
Chinese spy and everyone knows it but
they moved to take our words down
foreign
ly inappropriate yeah stand by just a
second while we research the rule
and as we know how that turned out
ultimately she was banned from speaking
truly a disgusting person and it really
shouldn't come as a shock to us that the
same person who was stalking David Hogg
would behave in this way at a hearing
and this gets us to what I really want
to introduce to you today the anatomy of
the right wing propaganda cycle let's
see if we can figure out what mechanism
is at play underlying a lot of these
conspiracy theories
are you tired of using words like very
all the time very good very busy very
tired words can get monotonous and if
you're a non-native English speaker who
finds it tough to learn new words and
remember them and use them in the right
way in context maybe you just need to
change your learning approach I am a
non-native English speaker I learned
English very young but when I moved to
the United States from Argentina at the
time speaking only Spanish and the right
approach to learning new words is really
useful for communicating in any context
you should look into a book by Michael
cavallaro called the Epp method three
super simple steps to build and retain
essential vocabulary for adults they're
sponsoring Today's Show and you can find
it at MPC author.com this book will help
you improve your English vocabulary
tremendously even potentially improve
verbal scores on standardized tests it's
full of retention exercises words
arranged by themes examples in context
antonyms synonyms my favorite chapter is
called an exploration of death which has
words like lurid martyred Macabre it's
how you learn new words quickly but also
retain them for longer and the book is
fantastic even if you are a native
English speaker start growing your
vocabulary by picking up a copy of the
Epp method go to MPC author.com the link
is down below